E
ND
OF
SHATTERED WITH A
STEEL LEFT.
A WITNESS CAPTURED THE MOMENT
PELE TRIED TO BREAK IN.
>> A GROUP OF PEOPL PASSED
BY --
[INAUDIBLE]
AND THEN AFTER I PASSED HIM,
THEY JUST STARTED TO TRY TO GET
IN AND STARTED CRACKING THE
GLASS.>> UNION SQUARE HAS OFTEN
TARGET OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
AND LOOTING.
>> IF YOU'RE WONDERING HOW TO
STOP ALL OF THIS AND GET CRIME
UNDER CONTROL IT HELPS TO
REMEMBER WHERE WE'VE BEEN
BEFORE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS CHART.
IT SHOWS HOW POLICE BGETS HAVE
CHANGED SINCE 1994.
THE LAST TIME CRIME WAS
COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THOSE BUDGETS HAVE GONE UP 46%
IN THE LAST TWO DECADES.
NOW LOOK AT THE EFFECT ON
HOMICIDE RATES.
THEY DROPPED 32% PER CAPITAL.
IN OTHER WORDS, INCREASING
POLICE BUDGETS HELPS.
THAT'S PROVEN.
BUT IT'S NOT THE FULL SOLUTION.
COPS CAN ONLY DO SO MUCH.
YOU ALSO NEED PROSECUTORS TO
PUNISH CRIMINALS.
ONE RESEARCHER AT THE UNIVERSI
OF TEXAS FOUND THAT ABOUT 25% OF
THE 1990'S CRIME DROP CAN BE
LINKED TO INCREASED INSAR